так гатять зенітну ракетні комплекси
petrio вони вважаються однією з
найкращих систем протиповітряної оборони
далекого радіусу дії і дозволяють
збивати балістичні Та крилаті ракети а
також деякі літаки на великих висотах ще
задовго до їхнього підльоту до цілей
українці тривалий час вимагали від
західних країн захистити нерв лише у
жовтні коли дрони та ракети обрушилися
на критичну інфраструктуру українських
міст Німеччина поставила Києву першу
систему ППО Іріс те однак Україна
просить дати їй більше захисту від
нальотів І от нарешті Сполучені Штати
зважилися передати за Ісусом ППО які
досі не поставлялися а саме
зенітно-ракетні комплекси Patriot
Я вважаю це хорошим розвитком жаль
викликає На мою думку лише те що це
робиться настільки пізно і так повільно
імовірно багато чому можна було б
запобігти якби це рішення було ухвалено
раніше
[музика]
це не просто одна установка а по суті
інтегрований комплекс протиповітряної
оборони система охоплює територію у
радіусі до 68 кілометрів її радари Може
одночасно відстежувати до 50 та вражати
5 із них залежно від версії ракети
перехоплювачі можуть досягати висоти
понад 2 км і вражати цілі на відстані до
160 кілометрів За даними американського
центру стратегічних та міжнародних
досліджень для експлуатації однієї такої
установки потрібно близько 90
військовослужбовців
додаткова цінність з ркпріот - це
здатність збивати балістичні ракети
захист інфраструктури міст від іранських
та російських балістичних ракет проте
проблема не в тому що дадуть з ркпріот А
скільки їх буде розміщено
боюся їх буде недостатньо щоб повністю
покрити всю територію США мають реально
посилити постачання включаючи петріот
Москва в свою чергу пригрозила
наслідками якщо патріоти будуть надані
Києву однак на думку багатьох опитаних
ДВ експертів головним наслідком нових
західних систем буде тем що з їхньою
допомогою Україна зможе перехоплювати
балістичні ракети і це серйозно обмежить
Росію у можливостях подальшої ескалації
водночас міні безпілотники які Росія
використовують для ударів по об'єктах
критичної інфраструктури України
відстежити та перехопити найскладніше
через невеликі розміри та малом висоту
польоту крім того збивати їх
нераціонально з огляду на високу
вартість однієї ракети від Петрів у
Європі зрк патріот перебувають на
озброєнній армії Німеччини Нідерландів
Греції Іспанії Румунії також торік перші
комплекси доставили до Швеції в рамках
угоди укладеної ще у 2018 році у березні
Незадовго після повномасштабного
вторгнення Росії в Україну США
повідомили що надсилають перші системи
патріот і до сусідки України Польщі
закупівля двох комплексів Петрів
коштувала Польщі майже 5 млрд доларів це
понад чверть оборонного бюджету країни
на 2023 рік крім того Польща незабаром
Має отримати одну систему Петрів від
Німеччини таке рішення німцю ухвалили
після того як у Польщі поблизу кордону з
Україною впала ракета внаслідок чого
загинули люди
тим часом днями Зеленський оголосив
партнерам перелік зброї якої нині
негайно потребує Україна зокрема він
закликав Великобританію збільшити
постачання систем протиповітряної
оборони Норвегію комплексів на самс і
ракет до них а Нідерланди надати сучасну
драматику передусім танки Швецію він
закликав посилити українського артилерію
зокрема системами арчер а так У захист
не базерка рбс-98 і літаками гріпен у
Литви президенту України попросив на сам
із дзерка Стінгер у Латвії артилерійські
системи в Естонії артилерійські снаряди
та запасні частини до гаубиць давньою
Зеленський попрохав про системи Сезар
Фінляндію про засоби радіолокаційної
боротьби протидії безпілотникам і
комплекси mlrs ісландію про допомогу в
розмінуванні Зеленський також зауважив
що немає жодного пояснення тому що
Україна досі не отримала рішення про
надання сучасних та ефективних танків
зокрема німецьких леопардів 2 у
Німеччині досі точиться Ну Це дискусія
завжди були побоювання щодо ескалації і
діяти обережно це правильно але тепер ми
бачимо що коли був атакований Крим не
відбулося подальшої ескалації Коли
Україна відвойовує територію не настає
подальшої скалатці коли поставляються
артилерія та ракетні установки Росія не
посилює ескалацію тож можна мені
здається заспокоїтися і сказати Можна
постачати танки Це допоможе Україні якщо
Україна хоче продовжити успішно
відвоювати свою територію її потрібно
більше Танків і гусеничних автомобілів
ми бачимо Наскільки важко
збройно-транспортерами на колесах
особливо восени і звичайно навесні і
бмп-мардер та леопард-2 могли б зіграти
в цьому важливу роль
постачання леопардів крім іншого на
думку експертів допомогло б краще
розподілити навантаження між Європою та
США у військовій допомозі українцям досі
США роблять для Києва набагато більше
ніж його європейські партнери на
двосторонньому рівні в плані постачання
військового обладнання США залишається
найбільшим донором України з 20-тима
мільярдами євро за ними на другому місці
йде Великобританія 4,1 млрд євро далі
військова допомога Німеччини яку
оцінюють у понад два мільярди євро